the tallest building in the world is
surrounded by desert and see the Burj Al
Khalifa soars in a city that had fewer
than 50,000 people in 1960 less than
half the population of Somerville
Massachusetts then in 50 years
Dubai's population has grown nearly 50
fold and now that city has practically
become synonymous with clearing oil
wealth and high-tech urbanism through
the 18th century Dubai was essentially a
remote fishing village anchored by a
creek that still divides the city into
two halves
dyra and board Dubai in the 19th century
Dubai broke away from the shikdum of Abu
Dhabi
but both became crucial States Emirates
that were elide with Great Britain and
ultimately part of a British
protectorate that would last until 1971
the port of Dubai achieved modest
success during the British era as a
trading entrepot and occasional stopover
for steam ships traveling to and from
India Dubai sheikhs were always commerce
friendly and they did their best to
attract Indian and Iranian merchants
Dubai's most lustrous products with
pearls hunted along the coast for
centuries
and their prices suffered with the
introduction of cultured pearls in the
middle of the 20th century the seeds for
Dubai's post Pearl success were largely
laid by sheikh rashid ii the amir from
1958 to 1990 during whose reign the
city's population grew from 40,000 to
over 400,000 the Sheikh envisioned Dubai
as being the urban connector between his
region and the world and he tried to
achieve that end by investing heavily in
infrastructure he dredged Dubai's Creek
and then built a bridge across it he
built Dubai's first Airport and despite
British skepticism enlarged it to allow
jet airplanes in 1965 he opened port
Rashid name for himself of course in
1972 and then the Jebel Ali port seven
years later Jebel Ali is supposedly the
largest man-made Harbor in the world
the Jebel Ali port was joined by the
Jebel Ali free zone six years later free
zones provide lightly taxed and lightly
regulated regions to attract
international firms and industries in a
sense they provide business friendly
legal infrastructure to match the
region's business friendly physical
infrastructure betting big on physical
infrastructure can easily go awry and
Sheikh Rashid
early investments
Shirley seemed like big gambles today's
investments also have real downside risk
but the sheiks Gamble's paid off well as
he put it my grandfather wrote a camel
my father wrote a camel
I Drive a Mercedes and his success owed
a lot to oil the oil wealth of
neighbouring Abu Dhabi had been
discovered in the 1950s just before
Sheik Rashid began his reign Dubai
didn't yet have its own oil but the
Sheikh grasped how Dubai could get rich
shipping the oil of others serving as
the region's conduit to the outside
world
Dubai's own oil was discovered in 1965
but much of that wealth was plowed back
into building the city Sheik Rashid was
convinced that without investing in the
city his grandson would end up riding a
camel like his forebears while some of
the Sheik domes prefer to remain more
conservative and closed Dubai has been
relatively open to the outside world and
keenly aware of its need to attract
outside talent more than 80% of the
city's inhabitants are immigrants above
all from India and they are there not
just because of the oil the failings of
India's legal and physical
infrastructure and the easy air travel -
well managed to buy makes Dubai an
attractive place to do business
you can certainly meet professionals in
Mumbai who spend their weeks working in
the Emirates
and come home to their families on the
weekend Dubai's recent building burst
has captured the imagination of the
world the world's tallest skyscraper the
Burj Khalifa the world's 3rd tallest
hotel the Burj Al Arab which sits on a
man-made island the first of three that
are meant to be built and the world's
second largest shopping mall in a sense
Dubai's great building boom can be seen
as an attempt to keep winning in the
global contest to attract human capital
Dubai first made itself a good place to
work now it's shopping malls and
skyscrapers and its dolphinarium can be
seen as an attempt to create a consumer
City as well a place that is fun as well
as productive when talent is global
investing in quality of life is an
economic development strategy one mantra
is that cities should attract and train
smart people and then get out of their
way but has Dubai invested too much
certainly they were rough years in the
great recession Dubai had to turn to its
oil-rich friends in Abu Dhabi for
support the emirate is again running a
deficit in 2017 aggressive interest
her investment always runs the risk of
building too much too soon
things seem to have stabilized but I'd
caution against any city taking the
lesson of Dubai to be that cities must
have the snazziest most over-the-top
most extreme physical infrastructure the
right lesson the deeper lesson is the
Dubai has long recognized that it must
attract outside talent to succeed and
that is true for all cities human
capital educated at home and imported
from abroad is the real recipe for long
run urban success an infrastructure only
makes sense when it empowers and brings
value to the humanity that is the real
City
you